tu donnes fouesnant elle est très
gentille
lederrey dieu bénisse 1 sur ma vie tu
sens et dans les pays de l'est genre
totalement ligne par steam et enzo et
mettez leur accueil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
il
j'ai fait un petit pas de danse mais tu
fais là je la prenais un petit peu dans
cet album qui varient tout à l'heure
j'ai un match celui de ta meuf qui
excuse moi toi tu croyais que tu étais
pas du tout une émission le gars était
en chine at il été en chaudron avec la
meuf mais tranquille quad genre en train
de lui parle il avait oublié qu'il était
dans l'émission alors j'ai pris des
informations alors y apparemment elle
vit à paris
non oui et c'est sincère on dirait que
stéphane bern qui va nous parler d'un
château de foix et donc vous allez vous
revoir ou quoi do you want to see him un
regain d'i want to see you next one you
want
ouais mais frères voiture mon ex chuck
c'est le monde à l'envers il va à la
pêche on va là ils vont suivre sur mac
[Applaudissements]
l'amour que lui c'est un grand
romantique et show woman stikeman à ce
poste c'est une barre mon frère il a
d'autres monnaies a comme à sedan les
chauds pour faire du pointeau dinner
with you might be alors tu n'avais pas
envie sioux wayne ou en ce soir ce soir
on peut se sont anaïs pas c'est beau
y'est c'est changer les contacte alors
alors alors alors
[Applaudissements]
un taudis on va échanger les contacts
ces très mauvais à caplongue les huawei
changer les contacts on va se revoir si
j'ai une fille non ça voulait pas du
droit que tous to dinner with me ok pour
l'instant avoir tenté d'échanger les
contacts elle a dit et après c'était
sympathique peut-être elle dînera avec
toi c'est que tu fais ça pour l'instant
à y parvenir il le faut
[Applaudissements]